quella tutti i ragazzi di persone che
sono fa vj oggi siamo su e ion delle
cose chi con tre stanghette sarebbe il
videogame dell'attacco dei giganti che
avevo fatto tipo quando c'era il
garibaldi cielo che l'hanno aggiornato
di brutto da quella volta quindi voglio
vedere che cosa hanno cambiato visto che
continuate a chiederlo da quella volta
lì difficoltà a normale è la madonna sei
chef bello è un gioco dove si gira
dall'altro l'audio e bebè bellissimo non
si è sentito ancora un cazzo ebbene la
scorreggia si sente premi cuel e per
lanciare sono bravo perfetto ok
spiaccicate in faccia dai ragazzi
sfottiamoci del tutorial iniziamo a
bastonare perché qua io so già che fare
i culi è cambiato un sacco comunque la
l'ultima volta che ha spiegato è
cambiato di brutto l'orecchia è più
bella signore e signori lattazione
gigante è che sono caduto subito c'è uno
che i capelli bianchi sembra pino
insegno è una bella andiamo a fargli il
culo subito è ragazzuoli vediamo è che
si è seduto a terra sta cagando ragazzi
andiamo a disturbarlo mentre cagà vedete
ci sono questi giganti che sono noti per
essere molto sexy e per sedersi per
terra nascosta fra te devo tagliarti il
collo perché i capelli non ce li hai
molto ben tagliati indietro poi bravo
ecco questo si chiama body slam
siccome tu sei molto bello e morto il
punto debole dei giganti ragazzi la
lunga festa detto il papa lazzano pure
mentre lo batti dov'è che va a finire se
foto ragazzi su gossip titan segnare
signori vi presento goku super sayan
primo livello e cosa cazzo fare
vieni qui via difficili è che bello che
se non mi ha schiacciato per grazia di
dio che mi magnan ottimi magna porca
ladra ma preso e notista sta facendo le
sopracciglia zio che problema c'è ma
[ __ ]
minchia son finiti eccoli oh mio dio ma
quale al nano che urla di guerra è morto
a sì perché si è spaventato con l'urlo
che ho fatto c'è ronald weasley che che
è più basso di quanto mi dicono avrai
fashion dei nani soppiatto io un altro
poco ovvero il sì c'è anche le rughe
oddio no no no no no no stavo scherza al
6 alto fratello sto scherzando
e come faccio buttati giù questi sono
proprio i piccoli più incasinato pure
ecco negli occhi negli occhi caminotto
molto difficile no non ho nemmeno
tiratissima che cosa fai mikasa madonna
che nervi mondo ti spacco eccoli johnny
bravo non ci credo sono fatto così
applausi guarda lo guardano tira le devi
andarci dietro cosa fai ricavi sapere
sui calci in culo morirà un giorno di
mal di testa perché sta girando un
[ __ ] io tra l'altro non becco le
case per miracolo non so come ci credo
non ci posso caricare gigante lorido
minchia che ti riduco apprezzi ti
mettono nelle sorprese di nuovo di
internet ma bello grosso uovo guardia
tunnel vedete si si eccolo è morto male
di 40 anni per farne fuori un ovale ma
ha lasciato pure una tetta titan e
rennes
posso giocare con identità nella
difficoltà più facile questa che sto
giocando impossibile sono un titano è
mica che cazzo sei centrocampista del
barcellona e palma
nel dubbio tiriamo gli un cartone in
faccia perché è giusto enti zio e ti
devo riempire di cartoni bach
ecco bravo ma non al 2 slay che ecco
ecco quella che non vento dalla distanza
ciao fratello ronald come stai di come
ti spacco la famiglia di turismo non ho
fatto gol
contenti loro ragazzi mi importa
stai comodo zio scusami se ti sto
stanziando sui capelli ma è il mio modo
di fare le acconciature fratello poi di
esercizio è un 62 enne è morto che
ragazzi come un gigante cene se io fossi
il lumino di prima sarebbe enorme vuole
non raggiungere la grandezza del mio
pene da lionel messi il calcio di rigore
lionel messi bene messo il vero che chi
è qua l'ho preso perchè comunque ragazzi
col gigante quanti punti mi dai
è questo la madonna quanto enna nomi
chiama chi lo vedeva mai
ciao zio neanche lo prendere talmente
nano che non riesco neanche a picchiarlo
ma come e mi stai anche spostando zio
cervi lui non mi picchia cds mi muovo mi
segue e mi sfugge mi fa tenerezza
poverino avete di vedere un calcio frate
scusami ti ho preso picchia che mira
ultimamente mandato
l'umanità ha vinto premi t per restar
dare no grazie va bene così saluto
strutto
mamma per la verifica di matematica
chiusura che ho fatto un sacco di
esercizi ma ho preso lo stesso 4 ma mi
sono impegnato di giro ragazzi qualcuno
mi descrive a questo vi prego ho bisogno
di sapere che problemi a dalla vita
chicca cosa ti ho capito che il tuo
parrucchiere non ti ha fatto il taglio
decente ma inutili e tapis bongiorno
fine alle sue sofferenze frate perfetto
ma no che figo ma c'e online si può
giocare online
fantastico quindi ai giganti sono
persone alla ci siamo ragazzi ci riprova
non so come sono molto credo di caduta
ma si può morire di caduta si può morire
grazie no sono già morti penso io a
uccidermi passatisti ghiacci di
atterramento a marzo la famiglia non
solo si può sfruttare questa occasione
che non vi sono spiaccicato forza se se
ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta ucciso uno che si chiama
aberranti come fa camminare senza
camminare fratello ucciso il tuo
minchione qui inutile che fa il figo
citato mai valevano accederà cielo c'è
se è sono due e sono due ragazzi
medaglie dove sono le medaglie voglio
tutte stavo per dire come mi sono
salvato mi sa di no perche era ora che
mi facessero essere un gigante ebbene sì
che non ci pensi di per avere a che fare
bastardo pam l'ho preso sopra ad ora che
passa da ziad apposta e mi spiace mi
spiace la somma perché io la panza l'ho
allenata o distrutto l'umanità
fantastico ecco le cose non ci credo o
mi girano o cosa tocchi cosa tocchi star
di no no no
non è di per sé ma no perché tra tutti i
giganti che poteva essere sono questa
merda
va bene ragazzi concludo che l'episodio
è stato troppo strano ci vuole un
manuale dell'ikea per poter giocare a
sta roba perché è impossibile che i
ragazzi spero che mi sia piaciuto un mi
piace per i giganti che somigliano a
lady gaga e britney spears per ogni mi
piace che mettete un penny in più per i
giganti perché sono senza bene e questo
è un problema per i ragazzi si è visto è
piaciuto alzate un assetto come mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook come mi
vedono nello schizzo stato bello ragazzi
oggi siamo su ei
[Musica]